alright here we are folks in did
anything good come out of air two ones
visit to America well the fact that you
actually had a bunch of Republican
senators right behind Trump who were
giving no sway on the Russian missile
system he's bringing in on the sanctions
that they're gonna keep I mean Trump
wants to pretend that he's his buddy
what we've seen with all these dictators
Trump wants to cozy up with the American
system still works it actually stops the
president from doing what he wants to do
okay
will will president Trump pardon Roger
stone not before the election would be
my guess well he's going to be sentenced
on February 6 I hope he rosin him Wow
that son-of-a-bitch whoa oh my beer work
with WikiLeaks to destroy not just
Democrats but to destroy our democracy
so I won't be roast in hell and I wish
I'm at the sentencing hearing cuz I'm
gonna wear the best-looking red dress I
couldn't say
sit down and and try to work with a
foreign government that is trying to
destroy our country destroy our
candidate yeah they work to destroy
Hillary Clinton they weren't to sow
discord between Hillary and Bernie and
yes they took our emails took our
personal information and then they turn
against us in threatened our lives and
harasses caught up in jail thank God
what a damn jury how do you wake me up
like this strong work I have to work
very hard to forgive him Jamie knows
where I'm coming from
they threatened us they went after us
and he understood what was at stake
and you saw what the testimony said they
were a gleeful Oh screw them yeah it's a
bunch of bastards
let her say something about Roger stone
no I'm kidding go ahead no I mean he was
close lee atwater so you know birds of a
feather yeah he took pride in being a
dirty trickster I share her jubilation
about Roger stones conviction but its
way eclipsed by frustration right so
Paul Manafort has had his moment of
reckoning same for Michael Kohn now
Roger stone when does Donald Trump's
moment of reckoning calm
my frustration about that way Eclipse is
my jubilation about justice being served
well and you know not to always be the
person who's looking for doom and gloom
but that's one reason why he can't leave
because his choice is either stay in
power or go to jail
rips or sell that's I mean this is what
happens in third world countries
dictatorships you gotta stay in office
or those are the only two choices it is
exact off to beat an incumbent when the
economy is good and he's got tons of
money I don't think people realize oh he
has raised so much money that's way more
than the Democrats the point that he
wouldn't leave
certainly willingly if he loses but
there's also the question of when he is
acquitted he's going to believe
rightfully given the process right that
he can continue to interfere oh he's
going to run on it right well I mean nor
is he going to to actually ensure the
security of elections Visa Visa external
forces like the Russian so I mean there
are a lot of people out there they're
gonna think that this 2020 election it's
not legitimate like he's gonna run
numbers the malla report didn't get me
this didn't get me you never got me down
ray you never got me down that's what
he's gonna run Raging Bull god help us
if he's re-elected because he acts like
this in his first exact oh I know and I
mean if he was trying to break the
country he's not confident at it but he
might get it right in a no I you know
believe me I am [ __ ] in my pants
every day about that that because he's a
vindictive person they make medicine for
that yeah I know the Japanese actually
legal in this state now
we'll put some in my ball I feel like
the three of us should go away bill is
my brother from another mother well then
we better not mess around it will Trump
be able to give the supreme get the
Supreme Court to protect his tax returns
from being released okay that came out
today he's taking it all the way to the
Supreme Court his tax returns New York
says we want them I never thought this
would be that hard I didn't think a guy
could keep even if he's president could
keep tax returns secret because the IRS
has them yes it's not like they're just
in his safe
why are they not been leaked I don't
know why why aren't they why can't
someone do a covert action and and just
steal them or something I mean they got
they got the pets on a microfiche this
you put it near my underwear you then
Pentagon Papers they have to take out
dreams of the actual paper oh god damn
it now you got me mad we gotta go we
have a party to go to
they were terrific they were terrific
thank you very much my Christmas record
you